i'd like to back up and tell you one
story so i bought a dc3 and i had
connections down to columbia
to haul um to home marijuana and that
haul three three three tons a thousand
miles and land on a 1700 foot strip a
wonderful wonderful airplane there for
that is would you pay for that by the
way that plane if you can put it up john
65 000. you paid 65 000 for that plane
yes wow
and that's worth about half a million
dollars now
but anyway i was down there and i got
shot down shot blown by i'd sky by the
columbian
jets two jets that was during the world
series baseball game in 1981
and uh i got out of that plane and uh
was 11 days in the jungle and the other
the other couple of guys that was in the
plane they went down the road
and they spent several years in bogota
prison
and uh i went through the jungle and
rode dugouts and whatever i could do and
swim across rivers and i was 11 days and
that's when i uh finally came to a place
i could don distal heavy having square
airplanes and the indians would say loma
linda loma linda and finally when i got
to loma linda it was beautiful it was
like hawaii and world war ii airplane
sitting out there and i went up and
hello how did you get here you know and
and you don't know what this place is
this is loma linda headquarters for
missionary aviation fellowship for the
amazon and they flew me out
in that wonderful wow and by the way
we have younger listeners this is not
the same amazon
like the amazon company you're talking
about like amazon amazon yeah we are
going to have to clarify nowadays
because some people are thinking amazon
was founded in the 80s it's not folks
it's later on so so that happens and
then what happens at that moment how are
you getting connected with these guys
oh a guy came up and wanted me to know
if i would unload on a ship with
marijuana and wanted to give him a
hundred thousand dollars or something
and to buy the fuel to come up in case i
didn't there so they could go back i
thought that was a pretty good deal
but it was just a rip-off so i went down
to see him and
he didn't have the money of course so he
took me to see a man named fernando
cortrail
in medellin colombia and he was up on
the top floor
and uh
and he he he looked like winston
churchill or was a kind of like he could
speak a lot of language probably a
genius from no telling but he was drunk
and he stayed drunk
so
that's how and he said he paid five
thousand dollars a kilo
to anybody to transport his cocaine but
you see marta his wife and so i did and
and uh
so inside shader a woman from bolivia
sonia de attila
and high cheek bones and rabbit boots
and rabbit fur coat and she was kissing
him on all cheeks and said she was going
to miami to buy an airplane
and so he said you have an airplane
don't you roger for sale
so the lawyer there did so i said yes
and she said what kind i said a queen
there well she perk right up queen air
so
she said the price and he kept bumping
his hand up like that
so i made a deal to sell her the queen
hair and i had it broke down
and then when it came to panama and she
said well you have to go to santa cruz
bolivia to get the money
wow so her entourage and all got in it
we went to santa cruz and the police met
her with the flags flying on the old
limousines and we went out outside of a
santa cruz and
to underneath the water tank and there
was like a house made of marble square
like a mausoleum
and there's a fence around it and the
people were all outside the fence and
they were crying
and she what's the matter with you fools
and you're lying is in there eating the
baby
she had a mountain lion and she opened
the door and run in there and there was
a kitty about a 200 pound mountain lion
eating a baby on the floor it almost was
i mean i won't it was just gross would
have been eating a baby the maid left
the baby on the floor in this mountain
lion that she's petting her house is
eating it
what
yes
that's the most gruesome thing a
horrible thing i've ever seen in my life
it was just just terrible
i mean she finally took it away but the
baby was eaten done well some head and
some diapers and fun
dude
yeah
so
holy mo
seriously i'm in a completely different
place right now
and it was her baby and her no no no no
no no interested about this mountain
lion now than pablo escobar no i don't
know yeah it was and you saw this right
there when she pushed him away in a
blind line with all muddy mouth and she
grabs him around the neck and gets him
out of there and you know so roger i i
know we're going to get into pablo
escobar i know we're going to get into
some of those juicier stories
at any point you're already in a mexican
jail you're seeing babies getting eaten
you're getting your your your uh been
shot you've been shot at you you're
missing a foot almost
at any point you're saying babe like
is your wife not saying honey what are
you doing like just like live our life
in california or was the money too sweet
to pass up
did you know
looking at that time it didn't even feel
dangerous even those things happened
how's that possible i don't know but it
just didn't
what
you're seeing people lose their lives
you're almost losing your life and it
still didn't feel dangerous it it really
didn't i mean it's just like flying an
airplane and you land on a sand bed or
it's like a bush pilot and it was fun
and it was great i mean go down stay in
the nicest hotels in mexico and go
fishing and fly load back it was just
great how much how much [ __ ] did you see
growing up as a kid like did you live a
rough life like did you live a life
where you saw i lived in a
mother and father and grandma lived in
the ground
and it feels like you were raised with
right values i did yes of course i did
and then so as an outlaw yourself
you're you so you is it the thrill
is it the excitement is it money is it
let me get a little bit more is it what
what keeps you coming back
i don't know it was just it was just
like i wasn't i wasn't afraid of it and
it was a lot of money like now i'm
making a hundred thousand dollars every
time i want to fly an airplane down for
a little buzz and go fishing and come
back that was it yeah
so okay so if you want to continue with
the story so at what point do you meet
ochoa or pablo
okay these guys uh come up after i think
it was after the dc3 was shot down
and now i'm all right i can't go to
colombia and i've had some trouble in
mexico too there's things that i've
skipped
so
uh
i'm kind of out of places to go we went
to pakistan did a load out of there and
i did then went to thailand did a load
out of there big 20 ton loads unloaded
in british columbia flew it down in
float plains to washington state i did
what did the thailand deal make you to
20 tons
i don't know a couple of million dollars
i reckon you know couple million dollars
yeah and i got bought a system 206 was a
beautiful plane and flew it down how did
they find you because this is this is
pre anything so how are people finding
you through what contest not like you're
on yellow pages it's not like you have
an instagram you can't dm me how are
people finding you well this guy the you
know the the thailand deal was later on
with a guy named howard marx that wrote
the book mr nice you've heard of him
yeah he hooked me up and uh got it did
several times so he's because obviously
back in the days in the military that
was normal so i'm thinking if the
connection was any kind of a military
things like this used to happen with
some of the guys that were in the
military back in the days military bases
were a great place to smuggle drugs
right back in the days oh he had some
people that were doing it we
had some people to do it but
then
okay so a guy came up i mean uh
and wanted me to unload the ship and
then he stole the money and so i'm going
after it so he introduces me to
fernando corduro
and uh
so then his wife says we're having a uh
his birthday party
and so it was over on the pacific coast
and this this is another
story so i flew over there in a in a
plane with a commercial plane landed
on the pacific ocean it was like in the
jungle i mean it looked like you was on
as far away from
civilization you could get between
panama and ecuador
and they landed it must have been 300
people there
and that's when they was deciding i
think it was or i know it was the
beginning of the medellin cartel
they had ever actresses and actors and
stand-up comedians and judges and police
chiefs from all over and everybody had
their little bag of cocaine showing it
this and the other
and the party raged for about
two days and then the nice helicopters
went to flying away in the planes and
left us
poor folks there
and for the
so it was sunday
and a good portion of begone
and i'd taken some barbecue and went
around the log cabin and was laying
there in the in the uh hammock reading
mmk's the fourth pavilion and bow bow
and blood spattered on the book that i'm
reading
i rolled out of that cat out of that
hammock and kept rolling until i felt
safe to look up and i looked up and
there was a a young black man
a handsome man looked like he's about 22
or 25 and he was tearing the pistol out
of a
a colombian a white colombian man's hand
and he put it right between his head and
went click click click click there was
no more bullets in it and there was a
dog there a white bulldog with a
with a black spatch over his eye and he
was turning cartwheels and the blood was
flying
and i looked and on on the on the young
man was he had been shot in the in the
leg and he was bleeding bad
and i and so he hobbled backwards and i
said listen i told him in spanish i'm a
doctor i was lying but i could have
stopped it because with his fireman
training and
so he pointed that gun at me and i
didn't want that click click click in my
face and he hobbled on back i said
please man i'm a doctor i can help you
and he went on back down there and died
an old crone out came out screaming
all people are going to get in trouble
that night the generator went out it was
full of
water and
stuff when we went out there and we
could hear those people
under the trees down there
and we thought we was going to get
killed i mean sure enough and the next
day the place was the the runway was
covered in cans and trees and stuff so
that people couldn't couldn't land
and we stood up all night long to a
little
rags in nor cans so we could uh have a
little bit of light
it's a crazy story but how did you meet
pablo so now then
i meet somebody there yeah and
and he wants me to fly cocaine okay
so his name was uh jaime ordonis
and he had had a ton of cocaine
confiscated him from him in medellin and
he had killed 16 judges
is what i heard
so uh
i i flew down
and uh he was supposed to put 300 kilos
and i believe there's 165 in there and i
gave it to a guy named bill barbosa and
somebody shot him in the stomach he was
in the hospital two or three months here
in miami and i thought
he won't fool those people anymore so i
told my friend mario the one that
introduced me to him
and uh
he uh he says i got somebody to
introduce you to i've got somebody you
need to meet come down
so i came down and uh we went to uh
in vegata as a village just out of
medellin
and
we pulled up into
a like a little estate like an old house
with hitch and rails in front and little
stones all over and they must have been
30 or 40 men out there waiting to talk
to the
patrons
and so we was ushered right in and they
was a drop dead gorgeous woman in there
i mean she wanted to know if we wanted a
cup of coffee or tea so we had our
coffee and then we were introduced to
george ochoa jorge
and he was sitting at a big desk and he
was so nice he spoke some english and he
had 12 telephones all of them were
different colors and he tell us this is
new york and this is washington and that
in seattle he said when it rings i know
where they're talking from so i got
salesmen in that part another and he
told me i want to know what kind of
airplanes i had and what kind of
experience i had crossing the border
and i told him and he said well we pay
five thousand dollars a kilo for you to
bring it up
and uh we'll put it on and our people
will accept it up there
so he said let me get my partner
so he was going a minute and he came
back in with pablo escobar and pablo
escobar and a nice looking man
friendly and had a nice attitude doing
him shook hands asked me the same
question that or he had asked me
he seemed pleased with it and
that was that was how i met met him so i
started flying and they would put 300
they put 300 kilos on the first time
and then they i said it'll hold a lot
more but they wouldn't put it on for me
so after i don't know how many loads i
guess five loads or something i got
above the um above the uh fog and i
couldn't get down and i had to land at
uh new orleans international airport and
bounce down that thing in the fog and
sit there
all night with 300 kilos in there so the
next morning the sun's come up and i'm
like ouch i
and i took off and and went over where i
was supposed to do and got down and i
thought i'm not gonna ever do that again
i had seven million dollars at the time
and i said i'm just i'm through so i
told leto the man that i give it to i
said listen man i almost got killed i'm
not going to do it again
oh roger please please don't you know
anybody
so that's when i hired barry seale got
it
and then i hired another fellow at
california and
so i had two airlines going and i had
about seven of those panther conversions
and
i had two people buying cars
putting hydraulic jacks on them and new
hoses and new tires and
it was just like
bang bang bang bang so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]